[Musica]
beh questo mondo digitale
questa trasformazione digitale dentro la
quale siamo immersi
ogni giorno ci stimola nuove domande ma
forse ce ne è una che più frequentemente
ci viene in mente te mi posso fidare
mi posso fidare che riceveremo le scarpe
che abbiamo ordinato su internet mi
posso fidare di questo nuovo ristorante
mi posso fidare di quel driver liberi
invece del tassista che abbiamo
incontrato fuori dalla stazione e ci ha
fermato lì possiamo fidarci di trovare
veramente quella casa che abbiamo
ordinato e abbiamo prenotato su internet
e nei blog chain ci aiutano proprio a
gestire meglio questa fiducia
questa fiducia nel mondo digitale ma
come fanno
beh pensiamo a tanti computer tanti
computer collegati in rete come dei nodi
di questa rete e questi nodi che cosa
faranno controllano la validità di
queste transazioni ma transazioni
diverse possono essere lo scambio di
denaro possono essere lo scambio di
pratiche tra enti pubblici possono
essere la sottoscrizione di polizze
digitali possono essere lo scambio delle
cartelle cliniche tra ospedali ma lo
scambio di qualsiasi altro bene digitale
in effetti le blog chain proprio
distribuiscono ai nodi della rete
la responsabilità di fare il controllo
sulla validità e sulla consistenza di
queste transazioni e quando questi nodi
trovano un consenso sulla validità di
queste transazioni le mettono
in dei registri digitali e strutturano
dei blocchi di transazione di
transazioni concatenando li l'uno
all'altro e queste sono le block
chaining belle e block cenano tantissime
tecnologie ma di fatto è proprio questa
validazione condivisa che alla
tecnologia alla base di questa nuova
fiducia digitale e che magari ci aiuterà
a rispondere in parte alla nostra
domanda iniziale immaginava adesso
questa rete di nodi ed i registri come
un notaio ad esempio sarà capitato a
molti di noi di dover comprare o vendere
una casa e quando dobbiamo fare l'atto
di compravendita
abbiamo bisogno di un notaio giusto
proprio per non prendere delle fregature
e tra le altre cose questo notaio cosa
fa per esempio verifica l'identità delle
parti verifica che queste parti abbiano
effetti la proprietà o l'utilizzo o
abbiano diciamo la possibilità
fondamentalmente di potersi scambiare la
casa e soldi da una parte dall'altra
certificheranno la data ma soprattutto
verificheranno che la transazione
avvenga in modo consistente cioè avvenga
il trasferimento di possesso della casa
e il trasferimento di denaro
beh pensiamo alle block chain come a un
notaio digitale distribuito che permette
a persone ad aziende a processi a
computer che sono indipendenti l'uno
dall'altro che potenzialmente non si
conoscono e che non necessariamente si
fidano l'uno dell'altro di poter fare
delle transazioni sicure di potersi
scambiare dei beni digitali ma
soprattutto di poterlo fare senza che ci
sia un'entità centrale un'entità
centrale che controlla queste
transazioni che le certifica di fatto
senza le cosiddette
terze parti fidate ed è proprio così che
nascono le blocchi nascono proprio dalla
necessità di eliminare gli intermediari
in quelle transazioni online che tutti
noi facciamo nel mondo dell'e commerce
ma soprattutto per ridurre i costi di
transazione
in effetti il concetto le parole bitcoin
cripto valute sicuramente le conosciamo
meglio ci sono più noti ma di fatto
tutte hanno la tecnologia e blocca
indietro
e proprio questi registri digitali
distribuiti e tutti di fatto hanno
l'obiettivo di creare sistemi di
transazioni sicuri indipendenti basate
su questa validazione condivisa ma
soprattutto per ridurre il costo delle
transazioni
beh ma allora cosa c'entrano le block
chain con questa trasformazione digitale
la trasformazione digitale
se ci pensiamo un attimo ci fa muovere
su una sottile linea una sottile linea
di confine tra velocità e fiducia
e pensiamo a quella funzionalità del one
click check out che forse molti di voi
usano su amazon che con semplicemente il
tocco di un dito
il movimento di un dito facciamo ordine
pagamento molti di voi l'avranno usata e
di fatto questo ci toglie molti dei
controlli ci richiede molta fiducia se
non altri noi stessi ma d'altra parte
dalla nostra esperienza d'acquisto una
grande velocità una semplicità diventa
molto più piacevole bene le block chain
muovono in modo radicale questa linea di
confine tra velocità e fiducia e la
fanno proprio in quei sistemi
distribuiti che sono alla base della
trasformazione digitale e li rendono più
efficiente più sicuri e questo lo stanno
facendo sia nel mondo della tecnologia
sia nel mondo dell'economia ma forse
soprattutto nel mondo dei social media
beh nel mondo delle tecnologie pensiamo
a quei sistemi basati sui micro servizi
o sui big data ben questi in questi
ambiti non necessariamente ci sono delle
entità centrali che coordina do tutto e
forse non dovrebbero neanche esistere
queste tv dentità centrali e proprio in
questi ambiti le block cene avranno un
ruolo fondamentale per aiutarci a
tracciare i dati in modo completo per
esempio aiutarci a mantenere la
consistenza dei dati in una situazione
dove i dati sono replicati
volontariamente oppure a darci
trasparenza in queste reti complesse e
di servizi o darci affidabilità rispetto
a quelle fonti dati esterne che ormai
utilizziamo quasi sempre per prendere le
decisioni e nel mondo economico e nel
mondo economico
se è vero che la missione delle block
chain è quello di ridurre i costi delle
transazioni allora vuol dire che stanno
ponendo le basi lo stanno facendo
veramente di nuove catene del valore più
dinamiche ad assetto variabile
catene del valore che non avevamo
pensato prima pensate a quello che
succede nel mondo delle assicurazioni
adesso compagnie assicurative broker
possono offrire possono negoziare quelli
che sono i grandi rischi dei loro
clienti possono sottoscrivere polizze e
possono gestirle su tutta la loro vita
grazie agli smart contract e gli smart
contract sono proprio un altro pezzo
fondamentale nella nostra storia delle
blog chain perché gli smart contrast ci
aiutano a scrivere quelle che sono le
regole dei contratti quelle che sono le
condizioni dei contratti e soprattutto
ci permettono di rendere immediatamente
eseguibile quelle condizioni
contrattuali
quando si verificano proprio quelli che
sono le precondizioni a queste regole
quindi rendono veramente molto veloce ed
efficiente la gestione di tutto il ciclo
di vita dei contratti e riducono in modo
drastico le transazioni ma forse è
proprio nel mondo dei sistemi sociali
distribuiti dove block cenci potranno
dare più una mano dove forse potrà
essere maggiore il loro contributo forse
più auspicabile proprio per sviluppare
questa fiducia reciproca
pensiamo un attimo a quei fattori che
hanno messo in crisi negli ultimi mesi
la nostra fiducia nei social media e
quali sono stati le fake news le false
identità i trolls la mercificazione dei
nostri dati personali
belle e fake news è un qualche un
fenomeno con cui ci dovremo confrontare
molto nei prossimi anni e d'altra parte
i sistemi che abbiamo attualmente sulla
rete non ci aiutano molto perché sono
basati sulla raccomandazione
sull'interesse e basata sui like sulla
condivisione dei link su sistemi di
abbott beh sistemi fondamentalmente che
sono stati del tutto inadeguati le
tecnici hanno dimostrato che sono
facilmente aggirabili
da persone malintenzionate da robot da
entità dedite esclusivamente a
diffondere delle buffe delle bufale
sulla rete proprio con l'obiettivo di
orientare l'opinione pubblica
sfruttando quella grande potenza di
fuoco dei social media è per fortuna ci
sono alcune nuove società alcune startup
che stanno cercando di utilizzare le
blog chain per combattere le femmine usa
alcune di queste anche italiane e ce n'è
una molto interessante il suo costo è
molto interessante user fit che
utilizzando dei metodi di etere un
formalmente mentre crea dei protocolli e
delle comunità di validatori di notizie
dei validatori di contenuti che sono
remunerati sono remunerati in base al
lavoro di verifica delle fonti che fanno
e quindi sono incentivati a evitare che
queste bufale si diffondano sui social
media
beh l'altro tema fondamentale nella
nostra società digitale e la protezione
dei nostri dati personali
beh da una parte sicuramente la nuova
normativa europea premente qualcuno ne
ha sentito parlare la gil ipr sta
aumentando la coscienza e sta
accelerando quello che stanno facendo le
aziende per proteggere i nostri dati ma
d'altra parte dal nostro punto di vista
l'utilizzo delle blog chain ci può
aiutare ad avere i nostri registri
digitale delle nostre informazioni
personali e di definire e di eseguire in
regole per controllare il loro utilizzo
la loro diffusione e perché no la loro
remunerazione
anche in questo ambito ci sono alcune
startup interessanti dopo che lavorano
con le block chain per proteggere
l'identità digitali
per farci riappropriare dei nostri dati
personali il consiglio è di queste che
si chiama helix è particolarmente
interessante perché partendo dal
concetto che le identità digitali sono
il dna di internet allora facilità il
governo delle nostre informazioni
personali attraverso delle sotto
identità come degli avatar che
gestiscono tutte sole le informazioni
tutte sole le regole per gestire
particolari sistemi specifici sistemi di
autenticazione per esempio i nostri dati
personali per il nostro account di email
per esempio per la nostra smart tv o per
la nostra smart card ma alla fine quello
che sappiamo forse l'abbiamo sempre
saputo che la fiducia reciproca e di
fatto alla base delle nostre relazioni
sociali sia nel mondo reale sia nel
mondo digitale e come i social network
hanno creato l'infrastruttura per creare
queste relazioni sulla rete le block cei
nella loro evoluzione potranno creare
l'infrastruttura per sviluppare la
fiducia in queste relazioni
grazie
[Applauso]